lemurs are the most ancient primate
alive today and Madagascar is the only
place on earth where they live this film
shows the essence of lemurs it shows
their playfulness it shows their
different varieties and all the
different ways that they move there's so
many of them and they're so different
they're totally resistant because Pat
Wright was able to preserve Ramanathan
National Park and we're able to see the
ancient forests of Madagascar in the way
that it has always again it has species
which are larger and stranger than
almost any other rainforest in the world
this place is full of things nobody's
ever seen before
Madagascar is the only place in the
world where these animals leave one of
the most incredibly impactive teaching
tools believe in our smoothies
Madagascar is a real challenge and to
make a film like this in Madagascar is
just America filmmakers always try to
plan out everything that's gonna happen
and Madagascar you can't really make a
plan that's gonna happen because
everything happens at the last minute to
make this movie really come together we
relied on the people of Madagascar
lemurs of Madagascar the scientists from
all over the world
it's a come-from-behind survival story
that highlights their ability to survive
the uncertainties in the world that
they're presented with now lemurs are
extraordinary animals it's time that
everyone knew how great flavors are
there are the Midlands big ones and
dancing ones and singing ones I should
go there with him actually
island of lemurs madagascar exclusively
in IMAX theaters
you